[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de libre-échange
sur Public Sénat une conversation avec
celles et ceux qui font avancer
l'économie française vous connaissez
évidemment leur entreprise mais
connaissez-vous l'homme ou la femme
qu'il a dirige aujourd'hui libre-échange
avec vous Eric rappier bonjour bonjour
merci d'être là avec nous PDG de
Dassault Aviation bon être à la tête
d'un fleuron français
industriel aéronautique militaire on se
dit c'est un sacerdoce quand même non
vous imaginez sur le pont à travers le
monde toute l'année 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7e notion de dévouement non
c'est avant tout un honneur de diriger
cette entreprise parce que elle est
centenaire et c'est une entreprise qui
symbolise la technologie l'innovation la
réussite et donc c'est un devoir de d'y
mettre toutes ces tripes pour arriver à
faire en sorte qu'elle se développe dans
le dans le futur et aujourd'hui et donc
ce succès est réel et donc c'est pas du
tout un sacerdoce au contraire je
continue à prendre plaisir
à travailler et à diriger cette
entreprise qui est comme vous l'avez dit
un fleuron français quand on est j'ai
envie de dire seulement le cinquième PDG
d'un groupe fondé en 1929 ça donne des
responsabilités particulières oui ça
donne des responsabilités de diriger une
entreprise avec des femmes et des hommes
qui sont des ingénieurs qui sont des
techniciens qui sont des compagnons qui
donnent de la passion et qui apporte de
la passion à ce métier de l'aéronautique
et puis travailler pour des actionnaires
qui ont eux aussi cette fibre cette
passion historique de la famille
d'assaut donc ça donne des obligations
ça donne des devoirs on a un devoir
d'engagement un devoir de réussite pour
cette entreprise dans le présent et dans
le futur cette passion elle commence
quand parce que c'est votre père qui
vous emmène au salon du Bourget c'est là
que vous découvrez le monde de
l'aéronautique vous avez quel âge est-ce
que c'est là ou pas qu'il y a un déclic
écoutez oui le salon du Bourget a été
comme pour chez beaucoup d'enfants chez
beaucoup de jeunes un déclic cette
passion de voler qui ancienne
Icare déjà rêvait de voler et de la
rendre possible c'est quelque chose de
d'extraordinaire moi j'ai beaucoup
voyagé aussi mon père travaillait à Air
France donc déjà une sensibilité pour
pour l'aéronautique et je dois
reconnaître qu'en sortant de mes études
j'ai eu un film qui m'a donné encore
plus cette elle c'est l'étoffe des héros
où on voit à la fois un pilote d'essai
et des astronautes et vraiment ça ça a
scellé mon envie de de rentrer dans
l'aéronautique et d'assaut m'a offert à
24 cette possibilité à 24 à 24 ans vous
n'imaginiez pas j'imagine finir PDG ou
déjà vous aviez une forte ambition vous
assumer à l'époque non pas du tout du
tout l'idée de finir PDG d'une
entreprise aussi prestigieuse déjà
rentré chez Dassault était déjà en soit
une première réussite l'ambition est
venue au fur et à mesure une ambition de
de faire gagner la société de la faire
progresser et de toujours
aller de l'avant y compris dans des
périodes où c'était pas facile
rappelez-vous à une époque il est pas si
facile de vendre du Rafale c'est pas
aussi facile de faire en sorte que le
Rafale soit un succès ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui donc il fallait être capable
déjà d'avoir cette persévérance et donc
c'est plutôt de la persévérance et de la
ténacité que de l'ambition vous êtes un
ingénieur qui est devenu commercial
cette double casquette c'est elle vous
sied on imagine mais c'est nécessaire
pour réussir à ce poste là oui je pense
qu'il est nécessaire aujourd'hui pour un
patron d'entreprise de comprendre le
monde dans lequel il vit car ce monde
change très vite rapidement grâce à la
technologie grâce aussi de temps en
temps malheureusement à la géopolitique
qui n'est pas si si simple et par
conséquent si on ne comprend pas le
monde dans lequel on opère on ne
comprendra pas les produits qu'il faut
préparé pour l'avenir on ne comprendra
pas la manière la technologie qu'il
faudra apporter par exemple la
transformation numérique qui a été
absolument nécessaire on peut pas la
comprendre si on voyage pas dans le
monde et qu'on voit pas les progrès qui
sont faits dans le numérique dans
l'ensemble de ces entreprises il faut
comprendre c'est compétiteurs
avec qui on fait des partenariats et à
contre qui on se bat entre guillemets
tout ça est une à l'échelle planétaire
et donc il est très important d'avoir
cette double casquette et de comprendre
les besoins des clients comprendre les
besoins des clients intéressants parce
qu'on se dit que même quand on vend des
rafales ou des Falcones il faut aimer le
contact avec le client d'ailleurs on dit
de vous que vous êtes un séducteur c'est
vrai ça je sais pas faut demander à ceux
qui me côtoient ce qui est certain c'est
que vous voyez j'ai beaucoup travaillé
au Moyen-Orient au Moyen-Orient vous
commencez par boire le thé vous parlez
pas business vous buvez le thé vous
partagez un moment ensemble pour se
comprendre pour s'apprécier trouver les
les éléments différents qui peuvent vous
relier et faire en sorte que le jour où
vous avez besoin de parler boulot par
les business mais vous le faites avec
quelqu'un que vous avez déjà rencontré
et avec lequel vous avez déjà échangé de
manière générale en également de vous
avec crapier que vous êtes exigeant ce
qui est d'ailleurs pas contradictoire
avec le fait d'être séducteur exigeant
très trop je crois qu'on est jamais
assez exigeant l'important c'est d'être
légitime c'est-à-dire quand vous faites
une demande cette demande doit être
légitime quand vous
positionnez une performance que vous
souhaitez pour vos clients il faut
qu'elle soit ambitieuse donc
effectivement l'exigence c'est une
caractéristique pour faire encore mieux
par contre il faut savoir aussi être
capable d'accepter je dirais de se
tromper et donc on peut avoir des
collaborateurs qui seront on peut soi
même se tromper
l'important c'est immédiatement d'être
capable de rebondir c'est pour ça que
j'ai par exemple une culture plombé
toujours avoir un plan B être capable de
dans l'instant de comprendre si ça
marche pas dans sur cette voie prendre
une voix secondaire
tout le temps on s'en sert tout le temps
je vais vous expliquer
c'est très simple c'est que si le
plomber est meilleur que le plan il
devient le plan et si vous n'avez pas de
plan B et que le plan de marche pas et
ben vous êtes planté donc il est
nécessaire en permanence d'avoir une
culture du Plan B en réalité si une
autre façon de dire qu'on évalue des
risques et que face à ces risques on est
capable de trouver une voie pour passer
le problème alors Éric rap piège je sais
que la question va être difficile pour
vous est-ce que vous êtes plus fier du
succès et j'insiste commercial du Rafale
ou du Falcon c'est un peu comme si on
demandait un papa s'il préfère son fils
ou sa fille j'imagine je suis content de
la dualité de la société d'assaut à
faire à la fois du civil et du militaire
et que la réussite de Dassault est liée
à cette dualité donc oui je suis avant
tout très satisfait de la réussite du
Rafale en particulier
aux mains des forces armées françaises
parce qu'il a été fait pour ça et ça
réussite à l'exportation car ça permet
d'avoir une amplitude bien meilleure que
pour le sol client français mais au même
moment j'ai lancé des nouveaux avions
des nouveaux Falcon et la réussite de
ces nouveaux Falcon c'est pour nous
d'assaut et vraiment une ambition dont
on avait besoin dont on a besoin en
permanence et donc c'est bien des deux
côtés et les deux se fertilisent
mutuellement la réussite de l'un joue
sur l'autre et inversement le Rafale il
faut le rappeler désormais plus vendu à
l'étranger qu'à l'armée française
cathares Égypte un des Mirac Arabes Unis
Grèce tout le monde reconnaît
aujourd'hui le succès du Rafale à
l'export international mais c'est vrai
que avant d'en arriver là vous avez dû
essuyer des critiques incertain
d'assobashing à posteriori qu'elle
regarde vous portez sur cette époque-là
ou c'était difficile bah écoutez c'est
mieux maintenant que pendant cette
période là je m'en doute deuxièmement ça
forge le caractère quelque part l'échec
forge de caractère il faut il faut faire
face à ces échecs on a été long on a eu
raison avant tout le monde on pensait
avoir raison c'est ce qui nous a
mobilisé quand je dis nous c'est Serge
Dassault c'est Charlet delstens c'est
tous les salariés de la de la société
c'est la famille d'assaut qui est notre
réactionnaire principale et qui a
toujours cru dans cette réussite du
Rafale comme dans la réussite des Falcon
et par conséquent quand on traverse une
période un petit peu difficile comme un
désert il faut savoir en tirer les bons
les bons éléments et se dire que au bout
du chemin la réussite va arriver ce qui
a été le cas il faut y croire et être
patient et tenace sachant que
négociations peuvent durer des années
des décennies
sur des avions de combat oui les
négociations sont longues extérieur oui
en réalité les négociations sont longues
mais c'est le déclic qui est important
le déclic pour le client à quel moment
décide-t-il d'aller acheter un avion de
combat mais c'est une conjonction de
deux facteurs sont d'évaluation du
produit du Rafale est-ce que c'est un
bon avion est-ce que il sera utile aux
mains de mes forces armées et d'un
déclic politique un partenariat entre ce
pays acheteur et la France et sa
politique extérieure est-ce que c'est
l'heure de ces années ou décennies de
négociations avec Trappier que vous avez
appris la patience alors qu'on dit que
ce n'est pas votre nature profonde non
c'est vrai il faut que je me soigne
l'impasse des réussites très rapides
néanmoins finalement on se on se
retrouve patient c'est pour ça que
j'aime bien le mot ténacité aussi tenace
ça veut dire on est peut-être pas
patient mais on sait qu'on va y arriver
donc on continue et on abandonne pas le
chemin qu'on a pris au premier échecs on
en met un on en met deux et puis une
fine et le succès est au bout du chemin
c'est parce que la famille aussi vous
laisse du temps la famille d'assaut est
dans ce temps long qui est le temps de
l'aéronautique aussi c'est grâce au fait
qu'on a un actionnariat stable un
actionnaire qui regarde la réussite et
qui admet l'échec qui est sur du long
terme et qui a la passion comme nous on
partage cette passion de l'aéronautique
et ça ce partage entre l'actionnaire et
la direction de la société fait
qu'effectivement on peut prendre le
temps sur ces industries allons cycle
puisqu'on parle d'échec quand on voit
l'Allemagne qui privilégie les
Américains aux Européens en achetant
cette année 35 avions de chasse F-35
est-ce que déjà vous comprenez leur
choix
on peut comprendre leur choix et ne pas
le l'accepter c'est à dire quelque part
les Allemands sont très proches
de la Russie et elle craint la Russie
elle donc elle se mette sous un
parapluie américain j'achète le F35 du
reste l'admet tel quel puisque l'achat
du F35 distille les Allemands est liés à
portée les bombes nucléaires américaines
qui sont stockés sur le sol allemand
dans le cadre de l'émission de l'OTAN
donc on peut le comprendre mais on le
regrette on a parlé de passion
d'engagement ténacité si on parle un peu
d'éthique qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
celles et ceux qui pensent que la vente
d'armes notamment un certain pays peu
démocratiques cette immoral à morale je
le répète je me place à la fois pas sur
ce terrain et sur ce terrain alors le
premier réponse c'est ce sont les États
qui ont la responsabilité de cette
exportation donc en particulier en
France c'est le gouvernement français
c'est ce qu'on appelle un le processus
qui est placé sous le la direction du
Premier ministre avec évidemment
l'accord du président de la République
dans lequel sont représentés ensemble
d'acteurs c'est à eux de savoir si c'est
l'intérêt de la France qui prime
d'exporter des armes d'un point de vue
éthique
l'importance c'est d'avoir une industrie
de défense et de ne pas être forcément
dépendant d'un pouvoir tiers surtout
quand on est une démocratie et je crois
quand même que la France est plus
démocratique que beaucoup d'autres pays
et donc se dire que uniquement pour des
raisons éthiques et érigées par des gens
qui sont pas forcément des gens qui
dirigent
peu affaiblir le fait que on a besoin de
développer son industrie d'armement on
l'a vu au cours des des décennies
passées celui qui maîtrise les armes
maîtrise aussi la sécurité de son pays
est-ce que c'est vrai ou pas Eric rapié
que l'essentiel des bénéfices de
dassovation vient aujourd'hui des Falcon
c'est vrai ou pas non je vous l'ai dit
si on est une société dual les bénéfices
viennent manière et le civil et donc il
n'y a pas de il y a je ne peux pas dire
que c'est le civil qui tire la machine
d'assaut c'est la dualité notre bureau
d'études et dual nos usines de
fabrication dual donc tous nos centres
de dépenses sont dues donc on gagne de
par la vente de Falcon et de Rafale et
on leur réinvestit pour partir dans la
dans la société pour préparer les
produits du futur dans certaines
questions pour faire la transition avec
le Falgon notamment le 6x qui vient de
faire sa première apparition publique au
salon de Las Vegas et qui rentrera en
service mis 2023 vous m'arrêtez si je
dis une coquille il coûtera au bas mot
47 millions de dollars et ce qui va
permettre d'effacer l'échec du programme
5x qui avait été annulé en cours de
route oui c'est le plan B du 5x toujours
le plan B toujours avoir un plan B
certains ne souhaitent pas avoir des
plans B bah quand il y a un blocage sur
blogué oui c'est un plan B quand le 5x a
été arrêté pour des raisons que le
moteur n'était pas en adéquation avec
les performances qui étaient voulues
immédiatement on a choisi un moteur
alternatif Le Prat et Whitney huit12 et
nous avons adapté le 5x qui est devenu
le 6x à ce moteur parce qu'on fait
beaucoup les avions avec les moteurs
autour des moteurs et par les moteurs ce
qui donne la performance de l'avion
indépendamment de dessiner un bel avion
avec des belles voilures qui sont
capables etc donc le 6x c'est vraiment
l'avion à venir qui va rencontrer une
réussite commerciale et qui est donc a
commencé non seulement à être montré
dans les salons salon de eBay à Genève
salon de la NBA à Orlando mais aussi qui
a fait un premier tour du monde pour
démontrer sa fiabilité et être capable
de corriger les petites erreurs de début
avant qu'on le livre au client mi-2023
voilà combien de commandes sont passées
déjà là dessus ça on reste confidentiel
voilà on a un carnet de commandes
globale et on ne donne pas le détail qui
est garni il garde qui se garnit il est
garnit bon si on veut garni qu'en 2020
c'est sûr la période est plus propices
si l'on veut évoluer en voler en
polluant moins il faudra attendre le
Falcon 10x on sera en 2025 ça sera dans
trois ans
Eric trapi il vaudra avec 100% de
biocarburant de quoi réduire son
empreinte carbone de 80%
en vol est-ce qu'on règle ainsi une
partie large partie de la question de la
pollution des jets privés avec celui-là
avant toute chose je pense qu'on est
tous les industriels français engagés
dans la problématique de la de la
transition énergétique dans le défi de
l'augmentation des températures et les
émissions carbone donc depuis longtemps
nous travaillons depuis des décennies à
réduire l'empreinte carbone de nos
avions ce qui ce qui était le cas avec
un programme majeur qui est qui ont été
fait de ces 20 dernières années
deuxièmement nous nous inscrivons dans
les ambitions internationales parce que
on ne décarbonne pas l'aviation
uniquement en France si on doit jouer
sur le Mondial il faut avoir des normes
internationales donc on s'inscrit dans
ce qu'on appelle l'OACI l'oasis une
organisation internationale dans
laquelle il y a les États-Unis il y a
l'Inde il y a la Chine bien sûr les pays
d'Europe pour trouver des normes qui
permettent le le zéro émission carbone
en 2050 pour ce faire nous pensons et
nous soutenons toutes les actions qui
permettent d'avoir des fuel alternatives
comme vous l'avez rappelé aujourd'hui
nos avions existants sont déjà capables
d'admettre 50 % de fuel ça veut dire que
très rapidement si on avait des volumes
de fioul on pourrait réduire de 50% les
émissions carbone donc je pense que
c'est vraiment la solution à partir du
10x on pourra avoir 100% de fuel
alternative ou de fuel vert c'est ça
qu'il faut absolument développer et qui
est faisable et à moyen et long terme
pour décarboner en tout cas l'aviation
d'affaires et une partie de l'aviation
commerciale en attendant être à pied le
carburant des jets privés sera bientôt
en France surtaxé en gros c'est il y
aura une quand il y a une taxation du
kérosène qui sera alignée sur la
taxation du carburant du quotidien
est-ce que vous comprenez vous soutenez
cette décision du gouvernement non je le
soutiens pas parce que vous voyez quand
on va dans des grands pays comme les
Etats-Unis on nous accuse toujours nous
les français de régler tous les
problèmes avec des lois et des taxes
supplémentaires donc c'est une
illustration supplémentaire de la
réalité de la perception qu'on peut
avoir dans d'autres pays du monde je
pense qu'il faut au contraire inciter à
aller dans le bon sens c'est-à-dire à
décarboner cette incitation qui
permettent de trouver des technologies
nouvelles alternatives qui permettent à
l'innovation de prendre le défi c'est
par l'industrie qu'on arrivera des
carboner l'industrie et plutôt que de
faire des taxes dans l'entre-deux mais
plutôt que de faire des taxes qui ne
s'appliqueront que à une toute petite
partie du monde dans des pays déjà qui
sont plutôt moins émetteurs de CO2 que
d'autres y compris en Europe dans tout
un tas de domaines donc quelque part je
dirais
l'utilité c'est que mondialement on
arrive à tirer cette décarbonation
c'était d'ailleurs l'initiative du
président Macron quand il a fait le
sommet de Paris c'est bien de mettre
tous les gens dans le dans la boucle et
aujourd'hui c'est bien ce qu'on a pour
l'aviation au niveau de l'OACI au niveau
Diatta pour l'aviation commerciale donc
vous regrettez que l'aviation d'affaires
soit prise pour cyber on se dit que
parfois les gens confondent peut-être
avion privé enfin via son privé et jet
d'affaires il y en a un qui est pour les
vacances et l'autre pour faire du
business vous faites la distinction
entre les deux oui on peut même se poser
la question de temps en temps de savoir
si ce qui dénoncent sont vraiment des
gens qui veulent le climat qui veulent
l'environnement parce que ou est-ce que
c'est des sont des attaques politiques
vous savez
j'ai 2000 Falcon qui vole aujourd'hui
dans le monde 2000 sur 100% de d'une
année de de vol c'est l'équivalent de
quelques heures de trafic routier c'est
l'équivalent de 24 heures de streaming
sur les téléphones ou les ou les
ordinateurs
c'est l'équivalent de quelques jours
d'émissions des centrales thermiques en
Allemagne c'est la symbolique donc voilà
donc c'est une symbolique donc comme
toute symbole est-ce qu'on attaque
l'aviation qu'on appelle justement les
jets privés ou est-ce qu'on attaque
autre chose alors l'important en tant
que démarche scientifique c'est de
regarder tout ce qui émet du CO2 dans le
monde et de traiter en priorité ce qui a
du volume et de manière mondiale ça ce
sont les ce sont les bases de tout
raisonnement scientifique pas certain
que simplement au symbole ou sinon on
n'aura pas la réussite et la réussite
c'est bien de décarboner et de
d'améliorer le climat pas de faire des
exceptions symboliques et qui sont en
réalité des attaques politiques vous
êtes donc le PDG de d'association mais
vous êtes aussi depuis 2021 depuis l'an
dernier le président de l'UIM l'Union
des industries et des métiers de la
métallurgie qui faut le dire d'une
ébranche les plus influentes du Medef
donc c'est ta question pour le président
du Yémen est-ce que la crise énergétique
mais en péril la réindustrialisation de
du site France du fait de la flambée de
la facture énergétique c'est le prix de
l'énergie c'est envolée du jour au
lendemain à cause des conséquences de la
guerre en Ukraine et du robinet de gaz
qui a été coupé par conséquent il faut
se battre sûrement à l'échelle
européenne pour être capable de de
capter un peu le prix du gaz et puis
fabriquer un petit peu plus électricité
fabriquer d'électricité propre c'est
réellement les centrales nucléaires on
n'a pas d'autre solution que de produire
beaucoup plus d'électricité dans les
décennies à venir ou sinon ne réussira
pas la décarbonation on a une filière
hydraulique il est hydrogène pardon mais
pour faire de l'hydrogène vert il faut
beaucoup d'électricité donc il faut
produire de l'électricité oui je crains
que la compétitivité des entreprises
françaises compte tenu du modèle social
qui est un bon modèle mais qui est un
modèle dispensieux compte tenu du niveau
des impôts et bravo avoir baissé l'impôt
sur les sociétés bravo d'avoir commencé
à baisser des impôts de production et ça
va continuer et qui ne l'impactait que
l'industrie on reste un pays à
compétitivité difficile et donc voilà on
est sur le fil de cette réin
mondialisation ou des industrialisations
et vous vos Falcon c'est intéressant
c'est qu'ils sont produits on le sait en
France mais vous avez une grosse usine
dans l'Arkansas aux États-Unis pour
réaliser les finitions sur sur les
Falcones et la réalité c'est que
produire aux États-Unis ça coûte 30 %
moins cher qu'en France on ne se compare
pas un pays asiatique non c'est un pays
à haute valeur ajoutée ils ont des
capacités effectivement c'est moins cher
alors aujourd'hui c'est c'est malgré
35% parce que le dollar le dollar est
remonté pour l'industrie romantique
c'est mieux que le dollar soit haut mais
vous n'avez pas toutes les charges
sociales vous n'avez pas les mêmes
niveaux d'impôts et donc vous et puis
dernier point c'est que malgré tout on
travaille beaucoup plus aux États-Unis
qu'en France la France c'est pas moi qui
le dis c'est un certain nombre d'études
scientifiques on va dire comme ça
arithmétique montre que il y a pas
beaucoup de travail en France comparé à
beaucoup d'autres pays or cette
compétitivité elle est liée aussi à la
capacité de travailler et je pense que
le travail d'ailleurs doit être de
valeur remise au plus haut niveau c'est
ce qui permet l'équilibre de vie pour
sauvegarder notre
train de vie de l'État modèle social il
y a cette réforme des retraites voulues
par le Président de la République
pourtant c'est que les Français très
majoritairement n'en veulent pas ce
qu'il faut faire passer une réforme
contre la volonté du peuple je pense que
la situation se situe comme telle il
faut travailler un peu plus alors il
faut forcément une réforme des retraites
nécessaires pour remplir les caisses qui
permettent aux retraités de toucher leur
pension il est absolument obligatoire de
faire cette réforme il faut la rendre
cette réforme acceptable donc des
discussions sont en cours actuellement
avec entre les partenaires sociaux il
faut donner une chance de jouer sur les
paramètres
tous les syndicats sont opposés non non
ils sont opposés à un ou deux
totems mais
il faut rendre acceptable cette réforme
parce que elle est nécessaire donc elle
va être faite autant essayer de trouver
les bons paramètres qui permettraient
justement de la rendre acceptable le
grand public qui va le comprendre ils
travaillaient un an ou deux ans de plus
pour être capable d'avoir une retraite
un petit peu plus longtemps puisque la
durée de vie est quand même plus grande
aujourd'hui qu'elle ne l'était avant ça
paraît arithmétiquement logique donc je
pense que c'est un un effet de bien
expliquer ce qui va être fait et de
trouver les bons cas particuliers qui
est aussi permettent de rester à
protéger population peut-être que
difficile qu'on travaillait un peu plus
dur manuellement et qui sont plus
fatigués d'être capable d'avoir des des
voix qui permettraient de s'échapper
plus tôt en quoi le PDG de d'association
il reste quelques minutes à passer
ensemble à changer en disant qu'est-ce
qui a changé
de diriger chez l'homme chez avant toute
chose ma vie personnelle est restée la
même je suis attaché à ma famille je
suis attaché à mes hobbies la musique
l'histoire le golf voilà je reste le
même homme
à l'inverse tout expérimente de cette
nature vous enrichit
l'important c'est aussi d'essayer
d'enrichir les autres c'est-à-dire
d'être capable de travailler à préparer
un futur donc je pense que c'est plus
facile aujourd'hui me semble-t-il pour
moi que il y a 10 ans il y a 10 ans il y
avait une certaine appréhension parce
que dirigée d'assaut c'était quand même
quelque chose d'extraordinaire donc une
ambition forte pour y arriver
aujourd'hui c'est plus facile
aujourd'hui on s'attaque très
directement et malheureusement les
crises qu'on a eu de auxquelles on a eu
à faire face elle permet aussi de gagner
en expérience donc la crise du covid ou
finalement on a réussi à la passer à
s'organiser aussi bien chez Dassault
Aviation que au gif face l'association
de de tous les de tous les acteurs de
l'aéronautique que l'UM les acteurs de
l'industrie ça permet d'avoir cette
expérience et de voir les choses d'une
manière un peu plus sage l'important
c'est de c'est de diriger en ayant un
oeil à ses pieds pour pas chuter et
tomber sur un appareil et un œil sur
l'horizon pour être capable de préparer
le futur bon est-ce qu'il y a une
décision majeure que vous avez prise par
le passé avec Trappier et que vous ne
regrettez pas du tout à posteriori
pour laquelle vous êtes entêté à
l'époque et bien vous en avez deux
choses un je regrette pas d'avoir
toujours
agi pour la promotion du Rafale qui
maintenant reconnu par tout le monde
comme un succès succès aux mains des
forces armées succès à l'exportation
succès économique ça c'est la première
chose aucun regret d'avoir persisté avec
mes prédécesseurs dans ce dans ce
domaine deuxièmement je pense que le
plus dur pour moi depuis 10 ans a été
d'arrêter le programme 5x arrêtez un
programme d'avion c'est quelque chose
entre guillemets littéralement
d'extraordinaire et d'avoir été capable
de jouer le plan B qui était le 6x qui
arrive maintenant en service dans les
mois qui viennent et au contraire une
décision sur laquelle vous aimeriez
revenir en arrière
si c'était possible une décision qui a
postadrine n'était pas la bonne non il y
en a pas parce que finalement quelque
part on se dit que l'édition les a
prises avec une certaine expérience avec
le soutien de ses équipes et
je me retourne peu sur le passé pour
essayer de trouver les mauvaises
expériences
ce que je peux dire c'est que ça va
jamais assez vite dans la tête d'un PDG
on aimerait que la transition
numérique à plus vite on aimerait que
les développements aille plus vite on a
ce souci d'aller toujours plus
rapidement vers le but et nos clients
nous le demandent à l'inverse le monde
se complexifie la technologie se
complexifie il faut savoir la maîtriser
être capable de démontrer que l'avion
est sûr dans les agences de
certification
européenne et américaine et donc par
conséquent il faut aussi savoir prendre
son temps bon il y a le passé il y a
aussi l'avenir vous avez à peine 60 ans
vous êtes né le 1er juin ce qui nous
fait un point commun vous voyez toujours
pas trop de d'association dans 5 ans
dans 7 ans finalement il y a vous pouvez
faire autant de mandats que vous le
souhaitez tant que vous avez la
confiance de l'actionnaire on revient à
l'actionnaire oui moi je suis je suis
bien je suis et je me je me projette
dans les années qui viennent après c'est
entre l'actionnaire et moi de savoir à
quelle date j'arrêterai vous avez fait
toute votre carrière chez chez
dassoviation est-ce que vous
conseilleriez vos enfants aussi vos
petits-enfants de n'avoir qu'un seul
employeur tout au long de sa vie
professionnelle sa carrière chaque
enfant doit avoir ça à midi à sa porte
et difficile on a envie de conseiller
ces enfants on s'aperçoit de temps en
temps si on conseille blanc ils font
noirs et inversement je pense que c'est
à eux de faire leur carrière moi ce que
je pense c'est qu'effectivement quand
vous rentrez vous avez la chance de
rentrer dans une société comme d'assaut
si la passion vous anime c'est à dire
que vous travaillez avec passion
pourquoi aller chercher ailleurs ce que
vous avez déjà trouvé et là sachant
qu'il faut continuer à pouvoir vous
épanouir au sein de l'entreprise évoluer
être capable de d'y trouver le retour
que que vous apportez et par conséquent
faire toute une carrière dans une même
entreprise je sais que c'est pas à la
mode mais chez Dassault je pense que
c'est possible et que ça va se
poursuivre ta passion est toujours là la
passion est-ce que vous voulez transmis
on finit là-dessus vous êtes transmise
cette passion justement de
l'aéronautique à vos enfants vos
petits-enfants je crois que même si on
voulait pas la transmettre on la
transmet donc effectivement oui j'ai des
enfants qui sont dans aussi dans
l'aéronautique merci
Eric trap et pour ce libre-échange merci
ce fut un plaisir je rappelle vous êtes
le PDG de Dassault Aviation
libre-échange à revoir évidemment sur
Public Sénat et en replay sur public
sénat.fr à très vite
[Musique]